foreign
[Music]
to the speedrun compilation as we start
the game quick apology for the previous
video I know there were some audio
issues hopefully they'll be fixed for
this video and we're facing a 2160 with
black
let's get a sicilian going now one thing
I was discussing on my regular stream is
that as we get to the tail end of the
speed run you know 2100 plus I started
developing an inclination for playing
the Sicilians that I know best in the
openings that I know best and of course
my recommendation for beginner to
intermediate players as a kind of
Gateway Sicilian is the accelerated
dragon with Knight C6 but
um I got a lot of requests particularly
from higher higher rated viewers to play
at least one night orphan to play the
Sicilian that I know best to give you
kind of a window into what uh you know
opening knowledge looks like at a GM
level I did this in the last Speed Run
game with the French and I am actually
going to play the move D6 here now we're
not even facing the open Sicilian anyway
so it's kind of a moot point we would
have likely faced the rosalimo after
Knight C6 which I just don't know as
well from Black's perspective
so Bishop B5 check is what I actually
play with white it's called the Moscow
variation I've also heard it uh referred
to as the the canal variation after the
Spanish Grandmaster Esteban canal so
there's three possibilities here I won't
talk about Queen D7 there's Knight to C6
which is considered the the most dubious
but also potentially the most rewarding
of the options Bishop D7 is considered
to be the most solid continuation it
often leads to dry and drab positions
Bishop D7 results in a lot of draws the
line that I think strikes the balance
between being sharp and offering winning
chances uh while also not being
objectively dubious is Knight to D7 and
this is the choice of most top players
who try to play for a win here with
black
um I play it myself
so I'm gonna bring the gain down just a
little bit and this move A4 uh was
virtually unknown up until
a couple of months ago when I feel like
everybody started playing it at my level
and my theory is that this isn't some
sort of chessable course
um according to people in the chat this
is what Wesley so recommends in a new
testable course I have never been
particularly impressed uh with this A4
variation it's Ultra positional and a
lot of people just kind of blindly
follow the stressable recommendation
then they get a middle game and they
kind of have no idea what to do so in
response to A4 we start by simply
developing our Knight and making the
more natural move this forces white to
decide on a way of defending the E4 pawn
and the plus of inducing Knight C3 is
that if white puts a knight on C3 y will
not be able to play this position Al up
and style with C3 and D4 which actually
is a very common way that you follow up
in a lot of variations of of the Moscow
and so our opponent does play Knight C3
so here we're gonna likely transpose
into an open Sicilian structure not an
open Sicilian theoretically but an open
Sicilian structure will be reached if
white plays uh d2d4 and you might look
at this and say well why don't we play
E5 here and prevent white from playing
T4 well E5 is a very positionally
dubious move I don't think it's terrible
but I don't like weakening the D5 square
like that I don't see this necessity in
doing so because we actually welcome the
move d4 that basically gets us into the
night or structure that we wanted to
reach
um and so the way we want to play here
is E6
and E6 is uh the sort of gen move I've
talked about the shivanagan structure
uh previously it's a sicilian structure
where black basically has pawns on E6
and D6 as as opposed to a lot of other
variation where variations where black
plays E5 and I'll contextualize this all
after the game for people who don't play
the night or if or don't play the
Sicilian and you're hearing all these
terms don't worry I'll Define all of
them carefully and clearly after the
game
we want to talk about the shaven again
E6 versus E5
but the basic idea is that we're waiting
for white to play D4 and of course white
could also keep the center closed well I
could play this more modestly with C3
let's continue developing our pieces
with Bishop E7 but D3 is obviously not a
scary move and we can essentially do
whatever we can play D5 ourselves
so the more ambitious players they kind
of automatically play D4 I had this from
the white side in an OTB game a couple
months ago I I tried this uh myself for
white and I was just not impressed with
with the resulting position after D4
maybe the engine gives a small advantage
but we get exactly the kind of Sicilian
structure that we want so rajo asks why
not A6 so A6 is a move that we can play
whenever we want to play it the bishop
on B5 is not really a nuisance and you
might say well but doesn't it pressure
the night but the Knight on D7 is the
most well-defended piece on the board so
we're essentially saving the move Asics
for a rainy day when we play this move I
really want it to count so I'm kind of
waiting for the perfect scenario in
which to play A6 it's the concept of you
know like the threat is stronger than
the execution you could play it and it
wouldn't really change the nature of the
position too much but I I like the the
concept of keeping the tension for for
as long as possible and in some
situations the bishop on B5 is actually
a misplaced piece believe it or not
because in a lot of Sicilians you
actually want to keep the B5 Square open
for the Knight so for instance if we
were to park Our Queen on C7 that would
be a perfect instance in which white
doesn't want the bishop on B5 white
wants the ability to play Knight B5 so
white might even move the bishop away on
his own power to which we might reply A6
to cover the B5 square but long story
short we don't need to play A6 unless we
really want to and this might be a good
time to play it but I don't see a reason
why we can't first uh castle and
complete our tank side development okay
so now we have the open Sicilian Shivan
again structure with a couple of
modifications
um of course there's a queen on Z4
rather than a knight as is more
customary in open Sicilians and there is
a bishop on B5 which is also quite rare
in uh in most Sicilians of course in the
night or if this is impossible because
black plays Asics straight away
um now when you look at this position
and you're not familiar with uh the way
that the Sicilian works you you'll be
forgiven for concluding that white is
much better
spatially positionally you might look at
the D6 pawn and say well this is a big
weakness it can be pretty easily
attacked if white just piles up on it
but the magic of the Sicilian is that
very often on the surface black suffers
from all these positional weaknesses
um and it looks like white can do
anything that they want but the more you
analyze the more you realize that
Black's position is like wildly robust
it's very hard to break down and in that
way I would lump the Sicilian with the
king's Indian which is a very different
opening from a situational standpoint
but it's got the same charm where you
look at a lot of the positions and you
think well black is super cramped and
black has more weaknesses but concreely
dynamically black is a lot of hidden
ideas that redeem uh our position
so one of those ideas is obviously that
Bishop F4 here can be met with E5
and that drops a minor piece another
redeeming element of Black's position is
that while the pieces are lumped
together and while we are cramped
everything is sort of Defending each
other like the Knight is defended the
other night is very well defended and
the D6 Pawn is much much harder to get
to than it appears so we already
mentioned Bishop F4 some of you were
suggesting Bishop takes D7 and Knight B5
okay but even if white plays that we can
just move the D7 Bishop out of the way
and it's very very easy to defend the D6
Pawn let alone in some cases we can push
push D5 and that often creates
complications that are favorable for
black
so should black aim for D5 no no we
shouldn't aim to force D5 through but if
a good opportunity presents itself then
D5 can be a legitimate Central
breakthrough
okay so our opponent is gone into the
tank Rook T1 which I think is the best
move reasonable put piling pressure on
the spawn
so we have a couple of options so again
we can play an A6 but I think that we
should delay that move one move further
and complete the sort of
stock Sicilian setup there's one move
that's missing which would complete our
kind of shivanagan setup and I've
already mentioned this move and it's
it's Queen C7 and this is not a very
deep move it's just a developing move I
mean our Queen is better placed on C7
because it's x-raying the C2 Pawn it's
you know another defender on D6
and it's ready in in certain cases to
jump into C5
uh in case white screen departs D4 we've
got a sicilian that started out as a
Moscow variation or Canal attack and
kind of morphed into an open Sicilian
structure
so this gives us a chance to talk at
length about the kind of typical ideas
here for black
and we're probably still into in uh
Wesley's chessable course I would guess
like this position probably has been
reached many times before particularly
in the last year or so but clearly our
opponent is is on their own so Bishop D7
Bishop D7 Knight B5 is particularly bad
now because the C2 Pawn will hang and
that's partially why we put the queen on
C7 and the C2 Pawn is very very hard to
defend which means that oftentimes the
Knight is actually tied down to C3 okay
so every move I say this we can play A6
and I think now is finally a good time
to to force white to commit a placement
of the bishop so either
white will have to give us the bishop
pair which is good or
or why we'll have to move the bishop
away from B5 and this gives us a little
bit more breathing room we'll be able to
play D6 Bishop B7 kind of Hedgehog Style
we can play B6 immediately we can play
B6 here but the drawback is that white
might tickle us on the queen side of
this nasty little move A5 and I'm sure
you've seen this this sort of concept
before across many openings where white
or your opponent attacks the tip of the
punching
the difference is that if we play A6 and
then B6 we take the sting out of A5
because then we can just push B5 and
that merely helps us get a robust uh
Pawn chain on the queen side so these
small subtle
nuances each one on its own is not
particularly vital
but when you combine them and take them
together and you see a lot more of them
than your opponent well that's what
opening understanding is all about and
that's how you outplay people in these
relatively non-tactical positions Bishop
F1 Okay so now I think it's a good idea
to complete our development we still
have this bishop which still needs to
participate in the game and if you're
familiar with a hedgehog structure I
feel like I'm making a lot of references
in this game to like various structures
and stuff and this is not to sound like
uh you know
this is not to not to be deliberately
pompous but this really does resemble a
hedgehog structure which normally arises
out of non-e4 opening in fact it always
arises out of 90 for openings for
usually like Knight F3 and C4 uh it can
lead to the Hedgehog structure and I'll
delineated after the game but in the
Hedgehog you arrange these four pieces
precisely in this way and the chief
difference between what we have on the
board and the actual Hedgehog is that
typically in the actual Hedgehog white
spawn is not on C2 but on C4 and that
changes the nature of the position in
several pretty important ways which I
won't delve into right now
um in any case
once we play Bishop B7 we will start
exerting pressure on the E4 Pawn making
it more difficult for white to achieve
progress on the queen side but the
bottom line is that it's very hard for
white to come up with a plan here and I
don't mean to trash White's position I
think the position is probably about
equal
but other than superficial developing
moves white just doesn't have any entry
points again Bishop F4 there's E5
there's no other way to attack D6 with a
minor piece I would play Bishop G5 here
and there is a plan where you get that
Bishop from G5 to H4 to G3
in order to make sure that E5 doesn't
come with a fork but our opponent takes
a different path Knight D2 which is also
an idea that I've seen
applied in this position quite a quite a
lot so again this must be in in some
course and this idea must figure
promptly uh must figure prominently
in in that course
so what does our opponent want well our
opponent wants to reroute the Knight to
C4 clearly why well primarily to add a
minor piece to the D6 pod so I wasn't
quite accurate when I said that
attacking with the bishop was the only
way okay so let me think about this for
a second because can we prevent Knight
C4 well should we prevent ic4 probably
not because after Bishop B7 Knight C4 I
feel like we have plenty of ways that we
can defend the D6 Pawn
such as D5 which becomes a viable
Central breakthrough at that point
and D5 actually looks quite decent there
even though it leads to an isolate Pawn
because it gives us a lot of dynamic
chances so that's one option another
option is to drop our Knight into E5 and
I've done this as well with the idea of
taking the sting out of Knight C4 then
you just take on C4 and play this should
be seven you trade a pair of minor
pieces and you prevent white from
attacking B6
so it's a hard decision actually the two
big candidate moves should be 7 and 95.
okay I need to think in silence for a
bit because I want to make the right
decision
okay I have some tactical ideas
there
oh
okay let's go Bishop B7 my intuition is
screaming for this move I feel like this
offers the more exciting chances for
black would describing Black's play here
as tiptoeing its way through the middle
game to avoid being worse or losing
accurate absolutely not in fact white is
in a great deal of danger here
man you should never assume that just
because one side has a space advantage
that somehow that side is immune from
getting steam worlds in many of these
Sicilians black just suddenly develops a
huge initiative and before you know it
White's position is collapsing so
hopefully this game will fit that
narrative if I play this well
but uh in the headshot that's type of
game Arc is also very very common so I
have a cool tactical idea here
um and that tactical idea involves
allowing light to take on D6 so we've
talked previously about two types of
prophylaxis or defense you know one is
physical like we could try to defend the
D6 spot we could play the move 98 but
that's out of the question because it's
Uber passive we could play D5 and then e
takes D5 just leads to pretty wild
complications but intuitively those
complications don't appeal to me because
another drawback of pushing the Deep on
is that later on the Bishop from C1 can
come out to F4 and attack the queen and
our Queen is comfortable where it is
here's a cool thought apart from
defending this Pawn physically we could
also create a situation such that when
white takes the pawn he compromises
himself in some way and well what would
that look like well the chief drawback
of Knight takes D6 is that it opens the
D file there's a queen on the D file so
obviously what I'm getting at is the
move Rook d8 which Rook should we put on
d8 well that's a hard question as well
my inclination is Rook a to d8 because
I'd like to leave the other Rook on f8
in case later on in the game the king
side opens up the case for Rook FDA
would involve saying well then you put
the other Rook on C8 and that's a pretty
decent file but I'm gonna go with my gut
here and play Rook 88.
now I didn't say exactly what we
intended against Knight 66 I simply
explain this idea on a surface level
after Knight takes D6 I have a really
really cool idea
and it's a hard move it's a it's a hard
move to see and it's a hard move to
appreciate the value but I think it's
straw does anybody see it most of you
are probably going to be thinking Knight
C5
the Discover and attack on the night but
remember then white can secure the
Knight with the pawn the move E5 is very
unpleasant there so do you see a way to
circumvent that yeah the move was E5
preventing E5 and then driving the night
out and I think that won a minor piece
our opponent sees it Bishop G5 is an
excellent move okay now again we have a
pretty vast choice we could throw in the
move H6 then probably white would play
Bishop H4
not sure who that favors but I like that
concept
wait but H6 maybe there's Bishop takes
F6
then Knight F6 Queen B6
yeah that actually might be an issue so
we might just immediately want to go E5
and push the queen out of D4 which was
the move that I wanted to play after H6
Bishop H4 and E5 is also very typical in
in the night orphan in most Sicilians
um I even referenced that move a little
bit earlier when I compared it to the
shebanon structure and again this move
might appear like a big positional
concession because you're creating a
hole on D5 but when you look at a weak
Square you also have to factor in how
many pieces are actually eyeing that
square making it difficult to occupy and
here we have these two pieces the light
skirt bishop and the Knight and both of
them are very safe the Knight is
defended by the other Knight and the
light skirt Bishop is hard to dislodge
so the D5 score is a weakness and
certainly a lot of games are lost
because of White's control over that
square
but it doesn't sell the whole story okay
so our opponent is deciding where to put
his Queen
there is a move that I think white
should play here
but it's not easy to appreciate why the
queen belongs yeah and that is the move
so commending my opponent on excellent
positional play
the reason you want the queen here is
because if we now play H6 again there's
this super pesky idea Bishop takes F6
Knight takes F6 and suddenly the B6
spawn is hanging and I don't want to
give that pot away because then white
gets like a three-on-one on the queen
side and you know that's how you lose
but we need an antidote to that I
actually need to think about this I see
a move but the problem with that move is
that it does give up the D5 Square
on the other hand even when you give up
the D5 Square still the game is often a
lot more double-edged than it appears
so let's think what do we want to do
here
this ship C6 Maybe
then Bishop takes F6
no we don't want that B5 doesn't work I
think we have to go Knight C5 I don't
see an alternative not that I'm so
unhappy to make this move but I feel
like if white plays this accurately he
should be better
so somewhere I somewhere I made an
inaccuracy probably should have gone
Knight c295 probably should have should
not have allowed Knight C4 it's just a
it's just a very hard move to deal with
because it it pressures both of Black's
major weaknesses
so we'll check with the engine after the
game these are like super complicated
questions
yeah so of course white can play B4 but
remember that the E4 Pawn is hanging so
we could take on e4 and that looks
really good for black so the advanced
idea would be to take on F6 first and
then play B4
and then
okay we are not attaching a break so far
but my position is still solid but then
there are tactics yeah then there are
tactics
good
let's wait for our opponents to move
because this will determine a lot I
think white is two tempting options here
yeah our opponent plays the the one that
I missed from a distance I didn't I
forgot about B4 here and we're going to
lose one of these pawns I'm getting a
played but I believe in the in the
tenacity of this opening generally even
when you're worse than a Sicilian
there's going to be a trick there's
going to be some something you can do to
get out of a dubious situation Okay so
let's think here which Pawn do we want
to give away
which Pawn do we want to give away
we probably want to give away the d-pawn
let's go Knight D7
now obviously starting to look at my
opponent's clock a little bit and trying
to make moves that Preserve
the complexity because 540 he's spending
like a minute per move in you know four
or five moves it's going to be tough
okay so now we have to keep the bishop
so I feel like we have to go here
whatever the consequences we cannot give
the light squared Bishop up because if
we do then he would have complete
Monopoly over the D5 square and we need
to preserve a defender of that square if
that makes sense
yes so we lost the pawn but and and I
don't have much compensation for it so I
got completely outplayed in the opening
stage of the game tentatively without
analyzing I think my mistake was
actually to allow Knight C4 maybe it was
to play Rook T maybe E5 immediately was
better yeah probably it was probably the
immediate E5 would have avoided a lot of
the problems
okay so here I actually came up with a
really cool idea here I came up with a
really cool idea so you look at these
two pieces and obviously they're very
vulnerable because they're on our side
of the board so there's this move Knight
B8
and I saw this move when we were playing
Knight t7 so this is part of the the
appeal of of that move
and suddenly like two minor pieces are
hanging I don't see a clear way for
white to defend both of them
so this could turn around very very
quickly unless white is Uber precise
yeah this is what I'm talking about when
I say that in the Sicilian like in the
king's Indian there's always there's
always a trick to be found somewhere as
opposed to say like the Queen's Gamma
decliner or some drab opening like that
yeah so of course white is Knight B5 I
saw that there's a couple ways that
white could try to save the piece first
of all queens E3 does not work because
then we take the bishop Queen takes and
then we take the Knight and in that
position Knight B5 almost works but Rook
takes D1 comes with check
hopefully you visualize that white could
also play Knight cb5 immediately but
that closes the escape hatch from the
bishop so if we could move the queen
onto a square where it couldn't really
be attacked easily white would run the
risk of just losing the bishop on its
own
and after Knight cd5 you have to
weigh the pros and cons of the various
Queen Retreats but the reality is that
black is only one feasible option after
Knight cb5 because if we move the queen
to the to the left then white can take
on B6 and kind of jailbreak the bishop
and at that point white is up three
pawns so remember white is up two pawns
were already flirting with disaster as
it is
the other option after Knight cb5 would
have been to take on C2 but still in
that position where I could take B6 also
the queen on C2 might end up getting
trapped like Knight cb5 Queen C2 rope DC
One I wouldn't even calculate further
that looks way too scary and that's
unnecessary because we have a viable
alternative like in an OTB game I would
even I would spend maybe like 30 seconds
calculating Queen sake C2 because the
the risk reward is is terrible it's not
like if the move works out then black
wins like it's just a freaking pawn and
you're putting yourself in immediate
Jeopardy of losing the game so by
process of elimination Knight cb5 we
play Queen C6
our opponent still is trying to find I
think some some like more natural way to
save the pieces and already down to two
and a half minutes which is really
really positive news for us
yeah but I hate to win any Speed Run
game on the clock and I'm not saying I
will it just is not unlikely but on the
other hand like I'm making this making
these videos for people who mostly play
rapid and woods so I think this is also
part of the part of the learning process
to see how complicating the game
can have this effect
even on very very strong players when
they sink into these long thinks whoa oh
and it works no way wait I just found a
crazy idea
I I mean I saw this move but I thought
we'd play Rook take C8 and we get two
pieces for it but then he's got Knight
A7 and then he's able to take on C8 with
the other night defending it I'll show
this after the game I'm in awe but I'm
not out of resources either I am not out
of resources either and we have this
move
which I think is a very serious move
which attacks the Knight on D6 and
obviously this Knight on D6 defends the
bishop on see it so
I'm just gonna play this move and force
our opponent to calculate because with
two minutes you can spend two minutes
here just like getting your bearings
yeah manka steer is the perfect like
thing to you know thing to say in this
situation
because
yeah now one one minute 40 seconds
I'll show all of these lines on the
board after the game which which are
quite beautiful
well we'll see
our opponent's running out of time this
is not a high quality game for me but it
still is is
ending in an interesting way so I don't
feel too bad about it
if there was a way to add time I I might
but there is no way to do that in
chess.com
at F5 what I expected so this attacks
the bishop and it doesn't just attack
the bishop it attacks the bishop with a
disastrous like family Fork so we have a
couple of options we can go back to
where we came we can play Bishop F6
and that will likely lead to a
repetition of Moves Like Knight E to D6
and then we go back to E7 Etc
are there Alternatives well there is a
crazy alternative to take on B4 but when
you take on before like anytime the
bishop makes a move in a position like
this you have to understand okay but
what squares now become accessible to
your opponent's pieces very important
question to ask and once the bishop
leaves E7 you should notice that the G5
square is accessible to White's Queen so
white could play Queen G5 or I could
play like Rook takes the Rook takes to
it and then Queen G5
and hit the rook and the G7 Pawn
simultaneously but the line doesn't end
there and I'm trying to calculate it
even further I'm actually inclined to
take on B4 we could lose the game
I 100 do not deny that but if my
calculation is accurate we actually can
get away with the smoke at least in a
practical sense where I don't think
white has the time necessary to figure
out how to punish this move that's what
all that's that's the way I'll I'll
frame it yeah I think white probably had
a draw there with Knight A7 as some of
you were indicating but in that case we
could have maybe taken on C2 okay so
what's going on now well now the bishop
is hanging why is it hanging now because
E7 is under control of the bishop Queen
G3 is the the more innocuous move
because this only creates the threat of
mate and it feels like our opponent is
starting to slip so here it's especially
important to be ultra accurate let's
weigh our options first option is to
play G6 that's I think the most
straightforward
but G6 maybe allows some crazy tactics
with Queen takes E5 and then we have to
take the Knight and expose our King so
okay it's an option but let's see what
else we have there's also Queen G6
so after Queen G6 if white takes on E5
we can take the bishop
and uh Queen G6 also threatens to trade
Queens which is really really good if we
end up winning a piece
so I'm not seeing a clear response for
white after Queen G6
I mean it's a wild position and you just
have to resign yourself to the fact that
the computer is going to see 8 million
times more than you will and and this
applies to anybody Magnus you know
Hikaru like humans have no chance in a
position like this to play well you just
have to play better than your opponent
that's you know that's the guideline in
these wild positions okay C3 but this is
a one move threat this tells me that our
opponent doesn't know what to do because
we could could grab the queen here
but the next level move would be Bishop
C5 just keeping the tension because
grabbing the queen would be wrong it
allows them Knight to recapture the
queen opening up a pathway backward for
the light squared Bishop so keeping the
tension here super important
very tricky concept there by our
opponent the other benefit is that if
white is the one to trade Queens we take
back with a pawn and we hit the knights
and then we guarantee that we win a
minor piece our opponent's running out
of time he doesn't see a move I think
he'll have to end up giving up a minor
piece and at that point will be a matter
of conversion eight seconds no moves
five seconds no moves
yeah he's gonna have to okay Queen takes
G6 is desperation we take back with the
H Pawn
okay well not totally desperation he's
still finding ways to keep the game
going and here I don't think we have a
way to win a minor piece but what we do
have a way to get is two pieces for a
rook and a really really good version of
two pieces for a rook so we play Rook
takes C8 Knight takes hit Rook takes C8
of course this is the better version
rather than first taking the Knight that
would be very bad because it would leave
the B6 spawn as a major weakness in
general as a as a guideline when you
have minor pieces against two minor
pieces against a rook the more pieces
our left's on the board the better for
the side of the minor pieces like if you
have another pair of Rooks on the board
he usually favors the minor pieces
because they have the drawback of not
being able to shuttle between one side
of the board and the other and if you
have a rook to like fill in the gaps
it's an Unstoppable combination now
we're in an end game so we gotta do end
game things and one of the no-brainer
like low-hanging fruit things we can do
is bring the king up to E7
just centralize the king you know make
sure that all of the infiltration
squares on on the D file are covered
it's a team effort when you have a lot
of minor pieces like this so then we
basically have to think recursively by
asking okay what minor pieces can be
improved what are their ideal squares
and what are the weaknesses that we
ultimately want to get to so the
weaknesses that we ultimately want to
get to well C3 and A4 are both weak the
E4 Pawn is also weak and one very
ingenious idea would be to do the
following say okay if we can force white
into playing F3 then suddenly the dark
squares on the king side become super
weak and we can actually try to set up a
mating attack in the end game
and the way to do that is to start with
Knight C7 and we want to go Knight F6
and this is not just a superficial idea
it's actually very hard to defend
against white plays F3 on his own
initiative
but now while we go Knight F6 anyway
we also could have gone like Knight f8
Knight E6 there's usually a lot of
possible Maneuvers in these types of
positions but we're trying to go for the
kill here and the Rooks are kind of out
of the game they're stumbling they're in
the way of the king yeah Knight H5
Knight G3 is a worthy okay G4 but that's
an wildly weakening move so I see we can
remove okay what is it weekend and what
are the squares that we could access
quickly well some of you might be
tempted to play Rook h8 but that's just
a one move threat the white king can
easily hold the H3 Pawn that's not where
we're going to infiltrate the
real weakness that this move creates is
the F4 square if we could occupy that
square with our Knight then the H3 Pawn
would be very hard to defend against so
you might say well let's fix the pawn
let's go G5 but G5 is a Tempo and every
Tempo is golden and I think we don't
need to play G5 so I think that what we
should do is go Knight H7 or Knight t7
and lead the Knight around to E6
I like in general going through the
center when possible because you never
know maybe you want to leave the H file
open maybe the night will be required
elsewhere
you just want to stay close to the vest
here
Rook D3
okay no reason for us not to continue
our maneuver but after white doubles
Rooks which I assume he's going to do we
have to pause and think for a second
because now of course 96 is associated
with a great deal of risk it allows a
check on D7 and that doesn't end the
line our King could run over to F6 but
that is tactical and that's complicated
and do we really need to allow that well
you might say well yeah we do because
otherwise what do we do but we've got
plenty of other things that we can
improve in this position
we could play that move G5 that somebody
else proposed Bishop C6 allows Knight A7
that is an undesirable trait although it
still is better for black I think but
one move that I do like which is kind of
similar is Bishop to B7
notice that we're keeping the Knight on
f8 to defend the D7 square and we're
trying to improve the position of the
bishop but we're also opening up an
Avenue to get to this A4 Pawn
we can't forget about any of White's
weaknesses we have to attack all of them
and that way you overextend your
opponent in fact Rook A8 is a great move
here now what does it give up well it
allows Knight C7 but that doesn't do
anything I think we just take on A4
there
I think we win this has been a great
great fight but now we're starting to
make serious progress because if white
plays Rook A1 then 96 already would have
been possible Knight D6 great attempt at
activity by our opponent but it's a one
move threat what do we do now
what's the calm simple professional
reaction to this move it's not to take
the Knight it's of course to play Bishop
C6 why C6 because now the bishop
controls the D7 Square so even if this
Knight were to move which I think it
very likely might then already 96 is
possible and once we get the knights F4
the game just ends immediately because
white collapses in all the squares okay
he blunters a piece
Bishop takes D6 he wants a rook takes B6
but in that case we could defend the
bishop with rookie hit but again we want
to play professionally we want to give
our opponent zero chances so let's make
this move first
threatening a fork this Knight isn't
going anywhere
we might even not want to take the night
we might even want to go for checkmate
directly in the event that the king
stays in this area of the board
um okay so here we should definitely
throw in
Knights F4 that's not gonna hurt
and then we could at least think about
setting up mating Nets
Rook D1
okay so here I've spotted a much easier
win and this is in the in the region of
okay there's a beautiful mating idea but
I'm not gonna do it because
that's not what we do on the speed run
it's in the region of not fixating on
Checkmate right so you might associate
this Knight with like part of a mating
net that you saw but you have to be
flexible because you never know what
role a piece is gonna have to play the
moment I say that you should see 92
check Knight take C3 but it's an easy
move to kind of tunnel vision past if
you're fixating on on shaqman or
opponent resigns good game
excellent maneuvering struggle or I did
get soundly outplayed in the opening so
we'll definitely need some engine
analysis I won't dig through chessable
to see which course this line is
mentioned and that's not
that interesting to me I think it's
probably Wesley's course but it's a
guess
so let's analyze
not for too long
so first of all a little bit of
definition the scamming and structure in
the Sicilian which is named after a city
in the Netherlands
uh but there is a shebangan variation
and the variation is rarely played
nowadays and it's to play E6 in this
position
nowadays it's been replaced by the night
Earth to a lesser extent the Rouser and
the dragon but E6 does exist and it's
been put out of commission in large part
by the Keras attack which is G4 so
that's one of the benefits of not
committing the E7 pod to E6
um in any case this gave rise to the
Excavating and structure which is
defined by open Sicilians where you've
got pawns on E6 and D6
the Hedgehog is usually reached via like
the Knight F3 and C4 Type move order it
can be reached in a million different
actual openings
and it's a setup adopted by black that
typically is characterized by
pawns and I'm just doing like very very
approximate moves to set it up the
headshot is defined by like these four
Pawns
and these four minor pieces like this is
the classic classic Hedgehog setup
probably this um
exact position has been reached on many
occasions
and as I said during the game the
placement of the pawn of the C Pawn
greatly changes the nature of the
position because when the pawn is on C4
you get kind of a marozzi bind formation
and you get a potential night sack on D5
so one of what's most exciting ideas in
the Hedgehog is to sack a knight on D5
and get like a long-term attack down the
e-file it's much more Uncommon with the
pawn on C2 so in any case that's the
references that I was making to the
Hedgehog let's get to the actual game so
Knight D7 was our choice
I'm not going to talk about the
alternatives to A4 with white eye castle
that's considered the sort of main line
nowadays
the older line that used to be played by
everybody was D4
CDL and queen D4 now it's kind of out of
fashion
and now of course A4 has gotten wildly
wildly popular
King
I'm gonna turn on the
the stronger stockfish just so we can
analyze this seriously so when I search
this online I see lots of games from
2023 tons and tons and tons of games
the first time this was played
this move A4
is in the year
let's see when was this first played I'm
just curious who actually came up with
this idea and Carlson has played it
1968.
by Arne zweig
from Norway interesting obscure game the
first famous person to play this move
was
let's see okay a Hungarian GM played it
in the early 70s so this idea has been
known for a long time but that's you
know what often happens in modern uh
play like these old ideas they exist but
then they're picked up on by somebody
and then everybody starts playing them
the basic idea is to keep flexibility
and expand on the queen side I don't
want to delve too deeply into it because
you know we want to fast forward a few
moves so Knight F6 Knight C3 E6 is very
logical
and this does follow okay A6 is more
popular according to the database Magnus
has faced the move G6 as well if black
wants to play this in a more dragony
Style
so A6 and G6 are the two most popular
moves E6 is third in popularity but it
scores really well oh we're following
the game nihal sarin against Dina
raditzki from title Tuesday 2023. I
completely forgot about that game two
months ago but maybe my opponent even
knew about that game nihal crushed me
and he crushed me in a very similar way
to the way that we got outplayed here so
I have some learning to do so
interesting against nihal I played I
played A6
and I forced him to commit his Bishop
and you can look at you can look up the
Neal game online
um but what happened was he dropped the
bishop back I played B6 I got this
Hedgehog set up and it you know the way
that this came wet is very very similar
Queen C7 he played Knight D2 and here I
should have played Knight E5 instead I
played Knight to C5 completely
forgetting that he could just send the
Knight back with B4
then he got his Knight to C4 I played
Rook to C8 and he just defended his
Knight with with Bishop B2 and black is
in huge trouble because now D6 cannot
really be defended I ended up playing D5
ended up playing D5 but
ultimately I just was so underdeveloped
that I got absolutely destroyed in this
game and by this point my position is
already residable so this is a dangerous
line if black doesn't play it correctly
and that's I think subconsciously why in
this game I wanted to delay the move A6
and so we played Bishop E7 D4 still
dozens of games in the database
cd4.d4 castles is the main move so we're
still following kind of central Theory
Rook D1 is correct
now Queen C7 nine games Christopher you
played it the main move with 18 games is
to play A6
and at least at a lower depth the engine
the engine does prefer A6
although Queen C7 is also pretty decent
it's giving like a very small Edge for
white but nothing major so definitely
our mistake didn't come until later
so our opponent plays this sort of
neutral move H3 it's been played once by
a Swedish GM and in that game black
responded with knights E5 and lost
but Knight E5 I don't really like
because this allows white to double the
Pawns so the engine in this position
prefers either A6 or B6 which is exactly
what we played so we went A6
uh the bishop goes back to F1
and of course white can also in these
positions contemplate Bishop takes D7
but after Bishop D7 apparently there's a
crazy tactic white can play Bishop F4
classic engine BS and who can tell me
what the plan is after E5 just amazing
how the engine always deepens your
understanding almost immediately with
these like wild tactics what's the
what's the point here for white well the
point here for white is to take with a
knight to take with the bishop but then
you have to calculate one step further
when A5 Bishop takes F6 white recovers
the piece the game continues it's
actually not totally clear but white is
better here yes plus minus this is
better for white so E5 is wrong black
has to make this very calm move Bishop
C6
the point is that if white takes on D6
which he should because E5 is already at
that point a threat you basically
liquidate into an end game where white
gets a minuscule Edge
but it's like Point 19 black should be
able to draw this pretty yeah this is a
draw I mean black is going Rook d8 on
the next move this is basically a draw
so this would have been one way to bail
out our opponent decided to keep the
bishop Maui played B6 top engine move
and after Knight D2 I was correct after
Bishop B7 it's still equal ish but I
feel like practically the position got
very unpleasant and then Rook a to d8
was a serious mistake and after Bishop
two G5 already white white has an edge
although still black could have kept a
better position so I don't think I made
one big mistake I think I made a series
of smaller mistakes and then E5 was a
huge mistake E5 is what takes it from
slight Edge for white to plus over minus
this was a panic reaction the correct
move here to jump forward a little bit
would have been Knight C5
and the move I was afraid of is before
but I forgot that the pawn just hangs I
don't know why I didn't play Knight C5
yeah Knight C5 is like totally natural
here
um white has to go E5 and bail out and
this is probably gonna lead to a draw I
mean
you're gonna basically trade all of the
pieces and this is a position which I
would consider agreeing to a drop so
so I didn't make any big mistakes until
the 14th movement until the moment I
played E5 but I think the position would
have been a lot easier to play if I had
simply got 95 and taking the sting out
of Knight C4 because here we play Knight
C4 white plays for instance Bishop takes
C4 though Queen takes is also possible
should be seven and from a distance I
was worried that after Bishop E3 we
would have problems with this spot but
here there are even some really really
cool tactics there's this move
and who can tell me what the follow-up
is to Knight takes E4 and that's not the
first the only move you can also go
Knight t7 but Bishop e494 is super cool
and it gives black an advantage
what's the point here
so it's not Knight takes and then D5
this is what you might think it is but
here white is able to give the bishop up
for two pawns and white is up a pawn
instead you play D5 immediately
and the point is that if white takes
then take back and you've got two pieces
saying and white is unable to give the
light squared Bishop up for two pawns
because you can recapture with the
Knight and black is slightly better
so after 95 a lot of you were asking
what happens after F4 and I think a
lower rated player would reject 95
because of f4 but F4 is an incredibly
weakening move and the reason that a lot
of people subconsciously
you know feel disgusted when a move like
app 4 is made is that you're forced into
making a retreating move I think I still
think that like on a primitive level we
associate retreating moves with
something bad having happened but
totally not always the case in fact the
Queen's probably gonna slide back here
and now black has another incredibly
strong move
notice the alignment of the king and the
queen so this is obviously a case in
which D5 is asking to be played
threatening this devastating pin so
white has to like start scrambling and
then we go here anyway
and after Queen H4 the computer has
another vicious idea which is Queen to
E7 and the point is that if white goes
here we go 94 Knight F2 check and then
we go whoa Bishop takes E7
you might think that you should take
back with a knight to keep the knife for
Texas but no the reason is that the
Knight jumps into D4 and black wins
material because white has no way to
defend C2 if white plays Bishop D3 then
obviously you take and then stick the
Knight stick a fork in it literally
now the engine is just ridiculous how
quickly it takes a position and just
turns it into
you know work of art
just sick tactics error but F4 is is
asking for it no GM would ever play this
move not even in a Blitz game just
because it creates these massive massive
weaknesses in the center
um
and that was a Black's only way at the
point so we played Rook Ada
and the idea was kind of sick if Knight
takes D6 just to reiterate E5 wins a
piece not the immediate night be it
because white plays E5 so first we play
E5 if Queen C4 then you can take the
Knight defend the queen and if the queen
moves back along the D file you have
this if the queen goes back to D2 you
have even this and the Knight is lost
so that was a nice idea but after Bishop
G5 I I got I fell in love with the
concept of like playing the move E5
and it was a completely unnecessary move
that weakens D5 helps the queen get to a
better Square it was a mental lapse
instead as I already indicated after
Knight C5 the position remains equal
after E5 it's plus over minus white is
like borderline winning already after he
after E5 so we played Knight C5 and here
again I have to commend my opponent on
like Ultra Ultra accurate play I think a
lot of people here would instantly play
Knight T5 and say oh I got an outpost
and I got a nice position and white does
have a nice position here but black is
still very very solid and The Rook can
be chased out of D5 eventually if you
get this Knight around to F6 so here the
advantage is manageable
but after B4 we end up dropping a very
important Pawn so Knight D7 Knight takes
D6 Bishop A8 Bishop takes A6 is correct
according to the engine so this
apparently is still the correct move
Knight B8 and white has some way to
maneuver out of the situation and it is
Knight B5 and it is Bishop C8 our
opponent was playing perfectly and I
guess this is a good time to explain and
to show what happens after Rook takes C8
so you might say oh well let's take and
then deliver a fork that would be great
but black can take back with a queen but
white knows immediately Knight ASAP
insane tactical eyeball my opinion I
didn't see this so the queen moves and
as a result you get a situation that
doesn't happen too commonly which is
three pieces against two Rooks and taken
alone that's about equal material but
look at the queen side why does like
three Unstoppable passers or white could
even play a five immediately it's
completely winning
completely winning which means we CA the
bishop is radioactive so my only chance
is it is to Peck at the Knight and try
to get it to move and it was only here
no still our opponent found the correct
move Knight F5 is correct oh this is
really sick so remember I said that in
this position we had a choice between
two
you're gonna love this
so if we had played Bishop F6 then the
other Knight comes to D6 and the point
is that the bishop can no longer drop
back to E7
and if in this position black plays Rook
takes C8 which is of course the the
reason that this move was originally
rejected
white plays Knight takes C8 and the
position is simply winning because okay
you play Rook takes C8 and here there is
a killer blow and this would happen also
after pain takes it and this is the move
Rook D6 and just look at these tactics
where does the queen go if it goes back
Rook F6 and queen H6 is just literal
checkmate
if the queen takes the pawn then in this
position again you play Rook F6 but this
time because you have a fork on E7 and
you win The Rook on C8
these simple lines mean that Knight bd6
wins but after Bishop takes B4 the
craziest move of all white is winning
here but only with a single move after
Queen G3 black is already better after
Queen G3 black is almost winning
although I made a mistake let's see if
anybody can spot the beautiful winning
idea here and give a Sully and it has
nothing to do with Queen G5
um if you're watching on YouTube great
time to pause and really you know give
yourself five minutes and and try to try
to figure this out so it's Knight B to
D6
they might look Knight B to D6 but
weren't didn't we just look at this so
after Bishop takes D6 white plays Rook
takes D6 sorry no that's not what I
plays oh why mates oh my gosh this is
even deeper than I thought here you play
Queen G5 and the point of this move was
to intercept the Queen's Pathway to F6
because if you start with Queen G5 black
can defend everything with Queen F6 so
this is interference
and now Queen G5 leads to a mating
attack which is still not totally
evident after G6
oh my gosh it's Queen to H6 another
piece SEC GF and then the bishop comes
back from the dead threatening made on
H7 you have to make some looks for the
king and now it's the classic mating
sequence incredible
I mean isn't that just lovely let me do
that again
he did everything right up until this
position I found all the best defensive
resources
so now again
the obvious idea is to take and go Queen
G5 but after Queen F6 black holds on and
the position is equal
instead white starts by throwing this
Knight onto D6 threatening the fork on
E7 so you have to take the Knight
and now it's not Rook takes D6
after Queen C7 black is still okay here
um it's suddenly to play Queen G5
G6 and queen H6
the running mate on G7 you have to take
Bishop comes back from the from A6 to C8
to F5 if you can believe that no it went
from B5 where did that Bishop it went
from B5 to F1
then it went to A6 to C8 into F5 that
would be the craziest path taking by a
piece like ever
amazing so here no Rook D6 loses Rook
d697 technically this is better for
black then the other continuation but
you can resign here you're down a queen
for two minor pieces
and as a consequence of missing it my
opponent gave away all his advantage but
in this position I also made a mistake
apparently Queen G6 allows white to
equalize
with a completely inhuman move okay
again it's crazy computer tactics Queen
B3 here is equal
early after Bishop takes E4 Knight H4
somehow
oh my God Queen H5 Forbes these two
pieces but out comes the bishop again
and it's equal
bigger Advantage would have been yielded
by Queen F6 but this is just computer
nonsense nobody can find this move at
least not in a uh in the confines of a
of a of a rapid game now my opponent
collapses C3
and already after Bishop C5
he's worse
but still the engine gives only a modest
advantage that's really interesting
so the the engine gives a modest
Advantage up until the point where he
plays rookie one this is the decisive
mistake
and you might hear this how could this
be a decisive mistake like he defends
the pawn what what happens after rookie
one is that I have to refresh
is that he he loses all of his ability
to be active like we get control of all
the key squares and the minor pieces
Prevail the only chance for white would
have been to like step on the gas pedal
and try to get active before black and
consolidates so Knight D6 is the only
move which gives white saving chances if
black takes and white goes after B6 so
black has to sidestep but if black side
steps then the Knight swings back to C4
targeting the B6 pawn and black is only
slightly better in fact according to the
computer Black's only chance for a
slight Edge is in fact to take and play
Bishop C6 and try to squeeze something
out of this position but white should be
able to draw with A5 so one very
instructive takeaway from this is that
mistakes often happen on the move after
you've transitioned into a different
phase of the game like whether it's
a sharp middle game to end game or you
know opening to quiet middle game a
mistake often happens on like the first
move of this new phase because you're
still
you're still playing on autopilot and
it's very important to stop reassess and
understand what your goals are in the
position so here you know that black is
gonna Massacre wide on all the squares
if white doesn't get active immediately
and so the move Knight D6 comes to mind
A5 would also be very decent just
sacking material in order to get active
see my voice is going
so anyways we're just about done you're
still probably why it should play A5 but
our opponent was like
that essentially given up
and one final instructive idea is this
idea of Knight H5 and uh Knight G3 one
very quick reference the first time that
I learned about this particular mating
pattern was this game
and I've shown this game before on
stream but it'll take on a new meaning
once you
have have fully committed this this uh
mating pattern to memory
so I'll fast forward this entire game up
until
the critical moment or the important
moment this was a fascinating game in
and of itself it's vaganian against
planets two GMS so in this position
blackis actor rook and uncorks a
beautiful combination who can tell me
what the winning move is
and this gets really really pretty so
you have to set up a baiting pattern
how does this relate to yeah it's not
Knight takes A3 it's Knight A1
this threatens Knight B3 Checkmate of
again says well I wasn't born yesterday
and he takes the plot on B7 what did
Black do now this is a real classical
game
it's an actual position from a game
between two GMS white was already losing
but this loses on the spot Queen to C7
check or queen C6
either move wins and either way loses
the queen or gets checkmated with Knight
to B3 so a good pattern to know the
bishop and nightmate which I don't feel
like is talked about enough in like
tactics manuals and stuff so another
just pattern that you should you should
be aware of going back to the game yeah
basically after G4 is played we reroute
our Knight again and get it to E6 I'm
sure that I didn't play perfectly here I
won't check this final part with the
engine I feel like my technique was okay
was enough to to win the game
convincingly uh if White had gone Knight
T6 here already we would have taken and
taken C3 in the floodgates kind of open
here black wins all the pawn so it's not
like a Dogma that you never trade minor
pieces you do if you have something
concrete you gain from it and once we
got the knights E6 and then the knights
F4 more resilient would have been Rook
D2 but here he would have taken that
third minor piece and defended our minor
pieces with the King and White's
position is residable anyway after Rook
D1 we went cleanly with Knight E2 check
so the final 10 moves were not as
interesting because once we got control
of all the key squares White's position
becomes increasingly harder to defend
again A5 should have been Automatic by
her opponent instead he went completely
the wrong direction so really really
beautiful details in this game
so to summarize my opening plan was
actually very good and we didn't explore
all the Alternatives I'm sure that there
are other good options for black like
playing E6 early or whatever but
first great thing to know is that Knight
D2 should usually be met with 95 in this
line see that's like a concrete takeaway
that you can apply if you get this type
of position
so Knight C4 yeah we play Knight takes
C4 but here white should probably take
with a queen and get into this equal end
game but
on
CE you allow Knight C4 you have to be
ultra precise
and don't fixate on the Move E5 another
good takeaway try to keep the pawns on
D6 and B6 as long as possible
this move would have attacked D4 and
still yielded a very tenable position
and then of course huge kudos to our
opponents I got sound layout played he
found a million amazing moves but you
know I found the only responses that
continued to test our opponent with a
minute on the clock each had just not
enough time to find this incredible
combination at bd6 and queen G5 there
were other ways I think to convert at
various points but like for example
white could have avoided taking on A6
and white could have just brought the
Knight back to C4 and this is probably
what I would do in a Blitz game because
this is a much easier position to play
because your next move is going to be
Knight C5 then you're gonna take with a
rook and you're basically playing
without risk
um
Bishop A6 is the correct move but it's a
very risky move and of course I I assume
he missed Knight B8 well if you had to
win with black you just play that end
game and you you try to outplay your
opponent
so amazing amazing tactics in this game
and you know apologize for the sloppy
play in the early middle game but I
thought my mistakes were just as
instructive as my opponent's mistakes
and this is the cool thing about the
speedrun when it gets more advanced I
also make these positional mistakes that
I learned from it and through the lens
of that hopefully you also pick up on
valuable
uh ideas about where to put your pieces
and where where you know where even good
players can can go wrong so don't feel
like in these complex positions a GM has
everything figured out I you know I'm
right there along with you trying to
figure out where my pieces belong it's
just I have more knowledge of typical
patterns I've had more experience with
this structure but it's not like I know
where the pieces belong or you know
which move has to be correct so
hopefully the audio quality was better
this time hope you enjoyed the game any
final questions thank you everybody for
watching
hope you have a great rest of your
Saturday
[Music]